[Music]
your son Oliver you have this gentleman
has one of most adorable kids in the
world I've met him on many different
occasions how is he doing he's great you
always describe him best that he like
he's like a 60 year old man compressed
down to a five year old yes and he like
he can't wait to her a suit that's the
epoch in my head he is so I took him to
see um brave the movie brave you see it
I did not go she ate your good old
juicer I did see brain did you love it
Annie now you are very literal you see
how you move that's true Andi yes
now you say did you like the movie - joy
brave brave I took my daughter to see it
and I thought it was pretty good kid
were you agreed not the movie as
advertised could we agree on that
yes I would agree a movie they make it
look like it's moving out a little girl
with long flowing red hair that likes to
shoot bow and arrow instead it's a
bonding movie about a mother and a
daughter bonding and at some point the
mother turns into a bear and has to
fight another bear to death and then
rips that Bears heart out and shows the
to her like it's patrick swayze in
roadhouse yeah and you'd look around the
movie theater jam matinee Saturday every
parent has a horde look on their face
like what are we doing to our kids yeah
I didn't see any of that coming by the
way
yeah it's a looks like a fun romp
well while that's happening I'm looking
over at my son cannot take his eyes off
the screen he's glued the screen it
finally ends and the credits start
rolling my son is on the edge of his
seat and he's just watching every word
of the credits go up and he's five
unless Hut and pig show up he's not
reading anything up there right he's not
gonna go dad is that gaffer or Jaffer
yeah yeah yeah so he's riveted but he's
River - what's the best boy dude he's
not thinking that so he's watching every
word and he's riveted every other kids
dumb and my kids just looking at it and
he's watching every word and I'm looking
over go this kid gets it this kid is
sharp he understands what's happening
here it's a Bonnie who he understands
his old man took me to a movie to talk
about this for the rest of our lives
the movie ends the lights come up my son
stands up and goes that's it I've never
seen that movie ever again
kid goes that's it my kid he hated it I
thought we talked about it on my
deathbed
instead he never wants to see this thing
again now I have to ask you and I am
name-dropping here yet your
father-in-law yes is walter Koenig who
played check off on Star Trek and just
an iconic year in the world of
television this is her father and he
recently is this right he was recently
honored he got through he got a star on
the Walk of Fame good for him and it was
a Carruthers yeah it was a great day
I've never been part of anything like
that I mean you know I'm in show
business certainly but this is a another
step up where like there's you know
paparazzi and they're good people and
there's you know like thousands of fans
there to celebrate this and I was there
with my son Oliver my beautiful wife my
mother and brother were there as well
and we're there to celebrate this and my
son it you could kind of see this on
YouTube he yeah just off screen you can
see the the thing that no man's up on
the podium talking about Walter canings
a great man this line this award is long
overdue
he's so deserving of this great honor
and just off you hear my son at butter
it's about 110 degrees outside you hear
my son go this is the worst day of my
life
I said I go I go out of her dishes a big
game for grappling as well it's a little
day for me you see me whisk him off in
the video like you you barely hear him
say though that I Wis come off so if you
look for that day you will get a nice
charge out of it